Trey my day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
And if you don't have this full range of
options and possibilities inside the
octagon,
you're most likely limiting yourself.
Agreed.
I see that.
Yeah,
possibilities are nice when you change
things up.
And again,
like we said earlier,
confused the brain,
get them thinking about something else
and then you do something else.
So that's always nice.
But I think right now we're seeing like,
um,
there's a,
there's a pack,
right?
There's like the standard pack of,
of athletes that are doing things in a
certain way and then there's a few that
are moving away from the pack and
they're expanding the potential of MMA.
I think you're one of those people.
I appreciate that.
And I thank you for sure.
And one of those coaches,
and there's a few guys out there I know
you don't like to hear,
but Dominick Cruz is one of them.
He's also doing it.
And we were,
we were talking about him today that
like his style is so fucking odd.
You know,
it's technically not sound actually,
but you know,
but he uses it the right way is he's got
awesome timing.
He's got a great cardio,
he's got a great Chin and then he can
get away with the bad things he does
cause he does them for the right way for
himself.
You know,
I don't necessarily think you can say
it's technically bad because he's so
fucking successful and he knows how to
do it.
I just think it's not standard.
You know,
like he doesn't like we're using Ramon
Dekkers as an example.
He does not throw kicks and punches like
Ramon Dekkers.
But what he does do is he throws him
like Dominick Cruz where he's moving
like a pendulum back and forth and it's
footwork is so weird and he's
overwhelming your mind with
possibilities and he doesn't do the same
thing twice.
He mixes things up so well that he's a
tough nut to crack.
Did he?
He's tricky.
He is trickier than I expected for sure
though.
You know,
a piece of that,
again,
game planning is the talks up to the
fight to get them emotionally invested
and then it becomes a bit trickier to
find the head.
Right.
So that's the goal.
When you were,
when you were leading up to the fight,
he was talking so much yet,
and you could tell that you were getting
so upset,
but that is a big factor in fights,
right?
Because fights are so emotional because
it's one of the only sports in the world
where your health is on the line.
Like literally like this,
the option,
it's not like you might get in a car
accident when you're racing cars that
that's a possibility.
But the goal of MMA is for you to fuck
up someone's body.
Yeah,
absolutely man.
Um,
the thing that I think with him too that
makes it pisses you off so much is that
he'll attack anything and just talk
about some of the Disney makes sense
just to talk and talk louder and faster
and not dot give you a chance to talk.
It's like a high school girls just like
bickering at each other.
I think that's what pisses you off the
most,
you know,
cause he's not even actually making a
great point.
He's just making it and making it
louder.
Voice.
Very articulate.
Yeah,
it was good.
Good analyst because of that,
you know,
and greed technique.
If you get a chance to find him again
for the title,
I bet you're paying the line.
Yeah,
right.
Obviously.
Well you lost a very close decision to
him and then you beat hot valence son
South,
which in my opinion was a,
we were talking about this today was an
excellent example of how far you
progressed because you guys had a really
tough fight.
The first time he fought it was a close
fight.
This fight was not close,
so you just ran away from him and went,
ran away with the,
uh,
the fight rather not wearing away from
him,
but rent.
I mean,
you were just,
it was a clear victory.
It's like you just were so much more
technical.
There was so many more options you were
presenting to him and he was basically
the same fighter that he was back then.
Maybe slightly better,
but you're all way better.
Fine.
I appreciate him and we,
we've worked hard.
We've worked long hours where it's
really hard.
Um,
you know,
it's crazy how the,
like you said,
the sport works out how quick things can
change.
You know what I mean?
I could be on 11 fight win streak right
now,
and a split decision loss to have fail
since.
So,
you know,
I thought I won that fight,
a very close fight with Dominick Cruz
that I felt I want as well.
Those two fights go my way.
I'm on 11 fight win streak.
You still have the belt,
you know,
known as hopefully one of the greatest
comp pound fighters in the world,
you know,
and we still sell stuff for sure.
Okay.